Arya Stark was born in 289 AC at
Winterfell during a long summer through
the course of our series she is a
character that has seen many acts of
violence including several killings some
of which she herself has been directly
responsible for although our story takes
place in a society where concepts of
adulthood do not match our own we must
remember that Arya is a child and
therefore cannot process the world in
the same way as an adult is it
reasonable to expect
Arya to grow into adulthood free of the
horrid that destroyed her you or is the
woman that awaits in arias future
someone were marked by her past in a
game of Thrones the first life of
several is taken by Arya out of panic
Arya kills a boy attempting to return
her to the hands of Queen Cersei using
the blade needle arya stood over the
body still frightened in the face of
death blood had gushed from the boy's
mouth as he collapsed and more was
seeping from the slit in his belly
pooling beneath his body she had to get
away someplace far from here someplace
away from the stable boys accusing eyes
Arya is frightened by the death but soon
gets over the shock in this case arias
actions are out of fear and defense the
next time Arya kills is again in an act
of defense in a Clash of Kings during
the journey with Joran of the Nights
Watch Arya takes down several of armory
lorch's men during an attack hardly any
time is spent on the effect these
killings have on arias psyche when later
Arya finds urines dead body she is
saddened but only because now that he
was dead he would no longer be able to
guide her to Winterfell he was going to
take me home she thought as they dug the
old man's hole he was going to bring me
safe to Winterfell
he promised part of her wanted to cry
the other part wanted to kick him it is
arias lured instance of killing that we
first get a glimpse of her callousness
towards death during her escape from
Harrenhal Arya kills a guard in order to
move beyond
castle gates Aria slid her dagger out
and drew it across his throat as smooth
as summer silk his blood covered her
hand in a hot gush and he tried to shout
but there was blood in his mouth as well
Adamo coulis she whispered as he died
when he stopped moving she picked up the
coin you killed him pop by gasps what
did you think I would do her fingers
were sticky with blood and the smell was
making her mayor skittish it's no matter
she thought the rain washed them clean
again
Aria kills the guard without the
slightest remorse and is unmoved by hot
pies astonishment all of the fear from
arias first killing has gone by now this
is the first of arias killings that can
undoubtedly be referred to as murder
the first was out of panic and the
others out of self-preservation over the
course of just two books Aria has grown
much darker and much more calm in the
face of death could this be hinting at
an even darker future for Aria in a
Storm of Swords the ghost of high heart
looks into arias soul and sees the
darkness within her you cannot hide from
me child come closer now code fingers
walked down are his neck fear cuts
deeper than swords she reminded herself
she stood and approached the fire warily
light on the balls on her feet placed to
flee the dwarf woman's studied her would
dim red eyes I see you she whispered I
see you wolf
child blood child but was the Lord that
smelled of death she began to sob her
little body shaking you are cruel to
come to my Hill cruel i gorged on grief
at summer Hall I need none of yours be
gone from here dark heart be gone the
ghost of high heart smells death on Aria
and is terrified by her is this death
that she smells on Aria from her past
killings or killings yet to come at this
point in time only four men have died by
Arya's hand and on the same Hill are
several men from the
other hood without banners who has
Outlaws have surely taken more than four
lives each so then why does the dost
fear are you so why is the smell of
death on are you more potent than all
the others the fact that the ghost calls
out Arya amongst so many killers can
only mean that Arya will lead to far
more death than the rest of them the
ghost also refers to Arya as dark heart
possibly a reference to are his growing
coldness in the face of death she even
cries and goes on to tell Aria that she
is cruel to come to her Hill if the
ghost is truly referring to Arya's
future as a cold-hearted killer then
there is more in our story that backs
this prophecy in a feast for crows Arya
murders Darion a black brother who
deserted the Nights Watch Darion is dead
the black singer who was sleeping at the
happy pot he was really a deserter from
the Nights Watch someone slit his throat
and pushed him into a canal but they
kept his boots good boots are hard to
find just so she tried to keep her face
still who could have done this thing I
wonder Arya of House Stark she watched
his eyes his Mountain the muscles of his
jaw that girl I thought she had left
Braavos who are you
no one you lie Aria kills Darion a man
she barely knows simply because he
offends her as a deserter of the Nights
Watch she follows him into an alley and
kills him mercilessly for this she is
punished with blindness by the faceless
men Aria throughout the course of this
series has gone from killing out of
necessity
in moments of fear or for the sake of
self-preservation to killing simply out
of desire at the rate in which Aria is
growing accustomed to death it is no
wonder why the ghost of high heart fears
her so is it Arya's upcoming future as a
faceless man that the ghost feared after
all the trail of blood that a faceless
man would leave behind would surely be
long
however the ghost also calls her wolf
child directly referencing her heritage
as a stark if becoming a faceless man
was an arias future she would have to
give up all that she was including the
name stark so are his future in the
house of black and white is likely not
what the ghost is referring to here
instead it seems as though the ghost may
have seen in Arya's future a singular
event an event where many die at once
she tells aya that she has gorged on
grief at summer hall referencing the
fire in which many lost their lives
including Jenny of Old Stone who if
you've seen my video on the ghost of
high heart likely could have been her
daughter it seems odd that the ghost
would mention summer Hall here
everything the ghost says seems heavily
weighted with meaning is the reference
here simply exposition informing us of
the ghosts past or did she see something
in arias future that reminded her of
summerhall
no one knows for sure why summer Hall
burned but one thing that seems
undisputed is the presence of wildfire
and here lies the key
King's Landing is reportedly full of
hidden wildfire King's Landing
the city were with Kevin and PI fell
dead Queen Cersei is free to rule as she
pleases King's Landing where the crowds
cried for her father's head and cheered
when the deed was done King's Landing
which took everything from Aria and left
her without a home and destitute
I have long expected that it would be
Cersei to perform the deed but now I see
that there is another contender could
Arya be the one to set King's Landing
ablaze killing all of her enemies within
Aria the wolf child aria the blood child
aria the dark heart Aria who knows
better than most that all men must die
the ghost of high heart looked into Arya
Stark and for an instant glimpsed her
terrible purpose a purpose of blood
death and unrelenting fire
you
thank you guys for watching if you like
this content feel free to check out my
patreon and make sure you like and
subscribe for more ideas of Ice and Fire
and don't forget to check out all the
amazing artists use in this video in the
description below